is the ROI um is do I have access to
more information better information than
I did without this platform do I have
access to more material information than
I did without this platform and that's
pretty much how we would run our trial
how we prove value what is it that you
know now that you wouldn't know without
us um for then there are other kinds of
use cases things like compliance due
diligence um sustainability where it's
it's more it's more of a process there
are there is some 20 25 uh step Che list
that you have to follow uh your Goldman
Sachs you're trying to decide if you
want to onboard a counterpart you'll
give a loan to a company there are steps
you have to follow you have to check if
the company's on a sanction list you
have to check if there if any of the
ubos have a criminal background you have
to check if the company has any previous
allocation of corruption fraud or
bribery so you have to do these things
um and there the Ari is you can do it
much faster if you're using automation
Andi then if you're trying to do it
manually
[Music]
Chan the N Jane thank you so much for
joining me in 20 minute leaders I really
appreciate your your time and you're
just after your office Christmas party
uh so we're in the end of December this
is great um very excited to have you
here um except to talk about your own
background H but also the background of
aquan and um understanding a little bit
better H really what it is that you're
doing transforming noise into knowledge
for financial services obviously we're
at a re Revolution all of us where the
data Revolution the AI Revolution and
there's so many different moving pieces
on how we are leveraging data and
knowledge H to to impact verticals and
industries um and so you're um obviously
in the dealing with some of the more
some of the most interesting pieces and
times in this world so H without further
Ado thank you again for for being here
take me a little bit throughout your own
personal Journey all the way up to the
founding of of aquan what how have you
gotten into this
space um I'll start by saying the way I
did it I would not recommend anybody
start like that uh at all having done
what I've done for the last four four
and a half years um I I started my
career in finance so I um started at
Deutsche Bank and then actually I
thought I didn't want to have anything
to do with Finance so I moved to the US
for a masters and um there was a company
called opto they were interviewing on
campus they had a very interesting uh
interview process the first round was a
math test you had to do 80 questions in
8 minutes and the cut off was 70 plus so
you know it was like I like math let me
see how I do on the test um I cleared
the test and then I was a poor grad
student with no money and they told me
if I interviewed with them I could uh
they would once my trip to Chicago
basically so that's the only reason why
I even went and interviewed with this
company but uh when I went there I
really really like the people that I met
um and how they were thinking about
trading it it's op is one of the largest
um trading firms in the world in listed
derivatives uh they headquartered out of
Amsterdam but they have an office in
Chicago because the C boo is there CME
is there um so yeah I just had a really
great time at the office with the people
that I met so I decided to go uh work
for them I did that for a few years
first in Chicago then in Amsterdam and
that's really where the idea of this
business even uh came about when I was
in Amsterdam I felt like I wanted to do
something of my own um so I quit I quit
without having uh a proper idea or a
co-founder or actually knowing anything
of like what it means to start a
business and what I'm going to do on the
day after I quit my job um and that's
why I do not recommend anybody start
like that probably better to start with
at least some idea that you have some
sort of belief in some or a co-founder
or some some um plan of what you're
going to do but anyways um yeah so that
was a few years back um and then we
applied to an accelerator program in
London called techstars um Tech Stars
they take uh 10 companies out of I don't
know some a thousand or so that apply
every year um for the company we were
building we knew that we needed to be in
a city with a lots of financial Market
participants and we also wanted to keep
an engineering team in India soand it
seemed like a good fit so we decided
we'll do the accelerator we'll see how
it goes and uh if something comes of it
we'll start this company and that's
pretty much how oan started um in terms
of what we do um so adopted I used to
trade arbitr
strategies and uh just like you would at
any of any such team we had a very big
data budget so we subscribed to pretty
much anything that you could think of
that would help us make better decisions
everything from like broker research
salite research very esoteric data sets
about the
company and we very quickly got into a
situation where there was just way way
more information to look at than we had
been with in a day um everybody on my
desk was reading all the time I was
reading all the time we couldn't get
through everything and uh it felt like a
lot of what we were reading was noise um
not not a lot of net new and and and it
also felt like we kept missing loads of
stuff so it was very obvious that the
way we were handling our information
flow was not very efficient um there was
probably some way to identify through
this very large messy complex noisy data
set identify the most important the most
relevant data points much faster than we
were doing and that's pretty much what
we now um aim to do with okon um to all
of our customers uh who are all in
financial services like um investment
Banks asset managers private Equity
private credit firms um we helped them
get ahead of their information flow
basically wherever there is a workflow
that requires looking through very large
amount of internal or external data to
make a decision we can help them find
that really material really significant
piece of information that um helped you
solve answer a question solve a use case
much much faster than if they were
trying to do it
manually how and so how do you even
quantify asess this pain point when you
when you want to you know think about
you know what's missing or or what
what's missing without a solution like
this is it is it mainly the proposition
that without a good solution like the
one that aquan is providing you're just
missing out on insights and you have
worse decision making how do you how do
you help Financial
Services understand that they're lacking
something here yeah so that depends on
the team and the use case that we are
selling into um if you think about how
the the the number of different uh
number of different functions that this
could impact it could be anything from
investment research where having better
access to data means you make better buy
and sell decisions you buy better stocks
you buy better ponds you sell companies
before there is a permanent loss of
capital um so in that case the ROI um is
do I have access to more information
better information than I did without
this platform do I have access to more
material information than I did without
this platform and that's pretty much how
we would run a trial how we prove value
what is it that you know now that you
wouldn't know without us um for then
there are other kinds of use cases
things like compliance due diligence um
sustainability where it's it's more it's
more of a process there are there is
some 20 25 uh step check list that you
have to follow uh your Goldman Sachs
you're trying to decide if you want to
onboard a counterpart you'll give a loan
to a company there are steps you have to
follow you have to check if the
company's on a sanction list you have to
check if there if any of the uos have a
criminal background you have to check if
the company has any previous allocation
of corruption for a bribery so you have
to do these things um and there the Ari
is you can do it much faster if you're
using automation Nei than if you're
trying to do it man
right and so you you I I guess it sounds
like there's a lot of tailoring to the
different verticals or within different
use cases for these for these customers
and so how how does an interaction
actually work from when you start
interacting with the potential customer
to the actual execution because I I'm
guessing there it's it's different
processes and how do you then think
about scaling that up so there is um
there is fine tuning to a workflow but
that workflow then looks quite similar
across customers um it doesn't matter
which bank you talk to they will be
running their KYB processes quite
similarly it doesn't matter which
private Equity Fund you talk to they
will be running their uh PE due
diligence quite similarly so we tailored
to a use case or a workflow we don't
tailor to a customer if that makes sense
um and actually it is intentional we've
decided to build things this way because
if you think about it um let's say
you're searching for information on on
um on Tesla then the system will show
you everything from uh information on
Tesla to growth in the electric vehicle
Market to human rights abusers in the
Cobalt supply chain in Congo um because
Cobalt is an essential part of the
electric the batteries that go into
electric vehicles it's a part of Tesla
supply chain if you're a compliance
analyst that human rights abuse piece is
the most important to you but if you're
an equity research analyst you care a
lot more about any expansion plans the
company has how the company's revenue
revenu is growing so the same product
cannot solve for both of them so you
need to build something that is very
verticalized very fine-tuned and
actually fits in the users's workflow um
so that's basically how we build the
business we we we work very closely with
our customers we try and understand what
their workflow looks like exactly where
it is that that paino is which is also
why I can tell you that for um for
compliance sustainability the pain point
is how long it takes to do that work um
and then for you know equities like how
long it takes to find the relevant data
is there a consideration of trust in the
communication with the customer or with
the relationship that you're having with
these with this
customer yes um and and also actually
there's another kind of trust which is
trust in the algorithm do I trust what
the system is telling me and am I
willing to make this based on that uh
right and that I I think that that
question of trust becomes even more
important especially if you uh in in in
the last year because if you tried to
use CH GPT you know the biggest
challenge there is hallucination it is
the system giving you information which
is completely fabricated um so it's
actually one of a very key criteria in
our system design how do you show the
user information that they can trust and
how do you give them uh the ability to
verify their information should it not
seem right to them so um and I know you
asked about trust in terms of
interaction with the customers yeah and
a lot of that is in terms of
confidentiality um it did closing
information to us that they do not want
any other customer to be aware of we we
make sure that information stays within
the users or a customers boundary um and
then there is some information which is
more General general purpose domain
information that helps us make our
models better make the overall
performance of the product better but
really the question of trust comes in
can I trust the information that your
system is telling me and one key thing
that we do on our platform uh we use
something called uh retrieval augmented
Generation Um on the platform so um
there's a lot of talk about generative
Ai and the benefit of generative AI is
when you now ask Chan g p your question
it gives you an answer it doesn't
perform like Google where Google will
give you 10 links and then you go and
read each of the links and you figure
out what the answer is it actually gives
you the answer right so that is very
efficient obviously saves you a lot of
time but you can't trust the answer um
the problem with Google is um you can
trust because you have actually gone to
the source and you have found the
information yourself but you need to go
find the information even if it's
telling you why the information exists
if you could sort of marry the two if
you could search for something in Google
you could get the links where the
information exists you could then pass
the text from those links to chat GPT
and then ask your question and say only
answer based based on this information
that I have given you and then get an
answer then you're guaranteed that the
answer is factual and correct because it
is based on this information that youve
given it and if you're still not sure
you can always refer back to the source
so that's the kind of experience that we
enabl on our platform for the customers
and so the way to do that is to
effectively monitor so the way to
enhance trust and reduce loculations is
effectively to to ensure you have better
visibility and coverage into the data
that is being fine tuned on because then
the responses repres are representatives
of the data that was fine tuned for
right fine tuning is one part of it so
there there's two key things that you
need to do uh one is fine tuning you
have to make sure that the models that
you're using they're not you could you
know start with off off the shelf model
but the model is fine-tuned on the kind
of data sets that not just your system
is expected to see but also data sets
that you consider credible you know if
you go and ask governance issues with
Tesla and CH gbt gives you an answer but
it's based on some uh propaganda that's
not correct right so you want need to
make sure that your modules are fine
tuned on data that you consider credible
and but that's only 50% of it the other
50% is actually feeding context to the
large language model so if you could
copy paste text from Google and put it
into chat GPD and ask it to answer uh
instead of relying on its own memory
that that is the other 50% that's that
is what rag or retrieval augmented
generation is so if you combine rag with
f you large language modules that's
really where you start to get
hallucination free credible answer that
you can verify down all the way down to
the source and you mentioned before a
little bit about the user behavior and
how to represent trust in the
in the confidence for the actual user
interaction with the software what what
have you discovered from a product
perspective that helps generate larger
trust in the user interaction with the
solution um even though they they don't
maybe they know that you have all the
all these great mechanisms for um for
you know mitigating the risks of
hallucinations Etc but but how do you
actually increase or alleviate their
confidence in the actual interactional
with your product
verifiability being able to verify the
information yourself I think that is
very very key u i mean if you think
about it in in your sense as well if I
tell you a fact right and if you don't
know it and you don't know me you can
think of me as a like as my platform you
don't know me it's a new product that
you just started using so you don't know
me you don't know if this the things
that I tell you are correct or incorrect
then you want to be able to go fact
check them you want to be able to if I
give you something that sounds quite
incorrect absurd orre reasonable you
want to be able to go search for it on
Google and say is what I'm telling you
correct uh that is pretty if you can
create that similar um the optionality
to do that in the platform that starts
to create trust you see something on the
platform you're like I'm not sure if
that seems right where did you get this
from you could go see the source and
you're like oh actually that does look
right that is what starts to create um
uh trust in the system so we do see that
in user Behavior early on users click a
lot on underlying data over time as they
start to build trust um that uh the
those that starts to go down but and
then that's when we know they're
starting to trust the information that
we're sending
them and where is aquan now from from a
company perspective you know if you're
looking at know we're right at the end
of 2023 you know where is if you if you
look a little bit from the side you know
where the company's at what what where
are you now and and what is what are
some of the exciting things up
ahead uh loads loads very excited for
2024 this year has been uh it's been
extraordinary for us um there there's
something we said about Market timing
and honestly I I was telling somebody I
don't even know how I was selling the
year before this because uh last year
the conversations used to be you need to
you need to start looking at Automation
and software and AI to solve some of
these problems that conversation's gone
there is already some sort of Education
in the market that uh some of these
Technologies are going to change our
workflows we need to start taking them
more seriously um it it has uh also the
ability to write generative summaries
has allowed us to do things that
previous viously one possible uh bring
even more productivity efficiency gains
to our customers so really in in the
next two to four years what we're
thinking about is what is the future of
a company like fax set or capiq or
morning star or msii you know these very
big financial data vendors what does
their future look like because their
business model is basically taking a
very large amount of publicly available
data setting up an offshore team and
using people to extract insights that
are then sold to their customers
um that that is a very it's a very high
cost operationally expensive way of
doing things um and you can only train a
set of people to do one set of things
you're looking at the exact same data
but one set of customers one set of
people are extracting Financial metrics
and other set of people are extracting
carbon emissions and then you sell them
as multiple different products uh which
means then for the customers of these uh
platforms they're paying three four five
six different vendors to pretty much do
90% the same job but you just need those
three four five vendors and these are
very very expensive products um we were
looking at fact set for example U all of
facts it's underlying data all of it is
publicly available data they don't have
access to any proprietary data what they
have built is taking that underlying raw
data and then curating it back into
insights that the customers care about
um now that you have large language
modules you have the ability to look
into these raw data sets extract key
insights using automation using AI um
that allows us to offer that those
products are much much cheaper um and
also offer across a range of different
products so that that that is something
that gets me really excited and and the
rest of the
team and perhaps the most important part
of this is you know what do you enjoy
most as an entrepreneur and know in this
journey what what are what are the
things that really you know guide your
inspiration and and really energize you
here um if you'd ask me like three or
four years back I had this whole idea of
we're going to change the world we want
to have a lot of impact but honestly in
the last four years the two things that
I've enjoyed the most is uh doing
something different every day it's it's
a it's a very Dynamic uh environment
here every month the the top of the Mind
problem that I'm thinking about changes
so significantly some days I'm thinking
about sales some days I'm thinking about
marketing uh love that and the second is
a team that I work with uh get to work
with some really really amazing people
um you get to choose who you work with
get to work with some really amazing
people it's it's really fun to come into
work so yeah that's it's incredible uh
Den I really
appreciate um the the time and the the
effort and the you know best of luck on
this journey it sounds phenomenal it
sounds like you're also extremely
rigorous in in the and meticulous in the
in the quality of the work and the and
making sure that you provide real value
to the customer it sounds like there's
you know the the the whole formation of
this company the understanding of the
paino the tuning and then understanding
how do you leverage the right technology
to actually extract the relevant
insights and how do you mitigate the
risks that the market is showing us
exist within this the within gen with
hallucinations and the lack of accuracy
and ultimately how do you then provide
the tools to the end user to to help
them really trust you H by empowering
them to do that and so I I think that
all around the towns care you're really
at The Cutting Edge of of everything
that's happening and thank you very much
for the time and for spending with me
and and best of luck with aquan thank
you very much and thanks for having me
[Music]